I'm gonna take picture of this and if
someone's like what are you going to
like look at it you see that that's
what's going up in here depression
causes logical thoughts of unworthiness
of just self-loathing having depression
is different than just one happy or
upset I stopped hanging out with all my
friends stop doing everything that I
loved
clearly isolated myself I was very very
very reluctant to talk to someone a year
after doing talk therapy and taking
medication the the benefits have been
incredible recently got this tattoo it
says you're not as blank as you think
I'm trying to find new places in my life
to find self-confidence and self-worth
and I finally started to talk about it
and come to terms with my depression and
really like face it head-on
hi I am Yao I'm here to draw your
depression today I'll Chi if I don't do
this tell me what does your depression
look like kind of like a never-ending
maze sinking but it's not like you're
trying to swim to the top you're just
kind of like almost peaceful acceptance
a darkroom that I'm trapped inside very
tall wall to the point where it's like
dark dark dark dark dark dark dark dark
dark light but the light is like a
really small rectangle looking up and
just seem like some light from the top
of the water like the Sun it's peeking
in I keep figuring out ways to let light
in but as I let that light in my
depression blocks light this maze is
like brilliant every time I think I got
it another like wall pops up or I'm back
to where I started I think like ocean
because rip tides they're things that
are beyond your control you have to be
careful I like to stay in the darkroom
even though I can see the world outside
I can see my family my friend dogs
nature you think of other people what do
you see you're blurry they're far away I
can't determine whether they're happy or
not in their faces and it's probably
concerning to me and makes me feel
paranoid that they're judging me or
tired of me the dumb little spots of
darkness will cause me to darken a
window and so it gets harder to see all
the things I love outside of the room
it's pretty just isolated to myself
which makes it hard to connect with
people sometimes terms of my tattoo the
tattoos to remind me like just look at
the wall to your left and look at all
the white outside there so what if it's
a little dark
everyone's room is a little dark but
it's not as dark as you think it's also
my cat Eva Eva's in the room with me and
when things get too too dark she
snuggles me and reminds me that I'm not
as lonely as I think you can't react
quickly even if you wanted to it's hard
to do things there's no like obstacle
that I have to like jump over it's just
me physically like getting
this cinderblock wall there's no end
goal in sight in terms of the light its
it's just a very faint light like it's
kind of beautiful life it starts very
bright and though stretches out it
doesn't touch me it's not that close
I've learned to get through it instead
of just giving up though I've never
gotten out of this maze because I don't
think I ever will and there is one door
a door I seem to forget about a lot a
door that lets me out to all the things
that I love holy crap you did that that
was like so quick that's really
beautiful I can't believe you did that
so quickly oh wow oh that's beautiful
it's like kind of stepping outside
myself and looking at what's happening
how do you interpret it there are
thoughts that you can't control that is
in your space so I put in your
depression rugs it's definitely there
with you but yeah it's not a part of you
you feel serene and accepting while you
are in that space so it doesn't feel
dark to me I didn't quit the end of the
tunnel so to speak that you described
it's just like somewhere in here that's
not at the end it's kind of on the top
you know it's somewhere I had the one
wall left over and then instead of all
windows and that's the door out and I
think that it's a great part of your
stories the fact that all of these
endings are kind of just open or someone
who doesn't know what it's like it is
never ending it's a battle that I'll
have to face every day for the rest of
my life I think why I like the way you
drew it better than how I visualized it
is cuz I feel there is hope in this
drawing it's always different to see you
from another perspective I mean
didn't make my boobs big enough I'm just
kidding that was pretty accurate
[Music]